[Music]  [Applause]  it hasn't sunk in yet was such just so  emotional I wanted to make sure that  this was we weren't concerned about  scores we wanted to go out and perform  this piece that was so special and on  top of that though getting those tens  and being the first it was pretty  special Monday it was most memorable  year night on Dancing with the Stars  for Jordan Fisher that meant 2005 the  year his grandparents adopted him  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  this is a story that makes me me it  makes me who I am and I've never shared  and not because I was ashamed of it or  anything along those lines it's just  because why tell it why is why who's  asking like it's nobody's business was  just a moment and I'm glad that it  happened the way that it did and it was  the piece that this this incredible  woman made and I'm just so grateful that  I got to share this experience with her  be able to share this story and be able  to share them on  [Music]  you